welcome everyone we have once again in
the next 15 or so minutes a presentation
from Donald Trump meant to propagandize
around his handling of coronavirus and
to stay away as much as possible from
any elements of medical being discussed
we know and we saw the last couple of
days that Donald Trump does much better
when he just has CEOs talk and talks
about how great everything is and stays
away from medical because for example
yesterday as soon as a question came up
do you think we can open up to 100%
before having a vaccine Trump said oh
yeah I think the virus is just going to
leave so every time that the topic goes
back to medical it's very bad for Donald
Trump and that's why we are seeing the
focus on just economic stuff today is
officially billed as president Trump
delivers remarks on protecting America's
seniors now the one thing that might
make today's briefing of today's event
better than yesterday's is yesterday it
was restricted only to in how a limited
pool of press corps and today I believe
it's the full White House press corps I
think from what I read so hopefully
we'll see some nasty questions by which
you know I really mean journalism
journalism and we're expecting that at
the top of the hour official global
coronavirus Kaye stole almost 3.3
million with 232 thousand deaths the
real number many times this of course
here in the United States we are very
very close tomorrow we will probably hit
1.1 million cases we are also at 63
thousand deaths Donald Trump initially
estimating the total death toll would be
60,000 latest that's estimates think
that a hundred thousand dead by August
is more likely and we continue to find
many many new cases here in the United
States we are sort of in a month-long
Plateau right now in terms of cases the
death numbers spiking significantly
Tuesday and Wednesday this week not good
the latest testing numbers yesterday we
tested 231 thousand people we still are
not
to fifty percent of the minimum starting
point that we need to be five hundred
thousand a day really we need probably a
million to two million a day quest
diagnostics has made available for a
hundred bucks an antibody test anybody
who wants to can get tested I'm thinking
of signing up and maybe getting the
antibody tests over the weekend or maybe
early next week certainly would be an
interesting thing for the show and I
will let you know what happens with that
and also want to mention a florida is
apparently hiding coronavirus deaths and
this should not come as a surprise to
anybody who's been looking at the
numbers florida's policies have been
terrible and they have 33 thousand cases
which maybe is the real number a little
hard to believe as you can see their
testing is very low the florida testing
18,000 per million massachusetts testing
38,000 per million but the death toll in
florida just seems low given the
completely incompetent republican
leadership from governor ron DeSantis
they're given that Florida's population
is the fifth oldest in the United States
it didn't seem right and now we do have
a whistleblower who says that State
Health Department intervened and told
him it planned to remove causes of death
and case descriptions from mortality
data so if you were suspicious that the
numbers in Florida seemed weird given
that they have 21 million people and
reopened beaches ten days ago you were
right to be suspicious and we will
probably learn a lot more about this one
way to hide cases is to simply not test
we've talked about that before a way to
high deaths is to hide the data and that
is what Florida is accused of doing as
of right now we will of course see what
other information we learn about that
welcome to everybody joining me once
again always a pleasure to have you we
are live on Twitter twitch YouTube and
Facebook
always always always remember when you
enter the YouTube stream smash that like
button and destroy absolutely rip apart
the subscribe button both are very very
important okay let me read some super
that have already come in and then I
have other things I want to go over with
you Zach bebo has subscribed on YouTube
Walker Anderson says when will your
first video release be on Tara read Tara
Oh Tara Reid I think I mean CNN and
MSNBC cover Tara Reid before you lol I
believe that there are currently three
videos on my youtube channel where the
topic of Tara Reid is discussed I have
three more coming out this weekend and I
mean what's the right number right I
mean 46 women have accused Trump of some
level of sexual assault my entire show
could just be about that I think I would
lose my entire audience if that was all
that I did so what is like the right
number of videos related to Tara Reid
which is it the only thing I should
cover should I be mentioning a daily
should I be like what should I be doing
but yes what I think believe I believe
we are currently at three videos where
Tara Reid has discussed three more will
be uploaded in the next 72 hours and I
don't mean it's six a good number I
don't know I'm just thinking out loud
here my friends
Martin Fillion has subscribed on YouTube
pear tieran says Sweden is called out to
make some good action at least love from
Sweden pear I don't know what you're
talking about but I always love seeing
you in the Super chats and very much
appreciate your support not Mart Fillion
said Oh Mart not Matt Mart says hello
from Quebec Canada where the situation
is following the same curve than the
United States a lost of trial and error
okay Ken Clive says governors are
showing good leadership in this crisis
would you like to see one of the good
governors Newsom Cuomo etc be Biden's
running mate but yeah I mean sure Biden
has already said that he's choosing a
woman so I don't know if he would go
back on that now feel Jay akhir says hey
Oh
Walker Anderson says why don't you cover
operation warp-speed it's good
mattias Germany says yesterday I hit the
like button and broke my phone yeah
Hayek
I actually I liked my own
yesterday and the my screen protector
flew off it was crazy it was it was such
an aggressive like motion that I used
unknown prodigy says a whistleblower
asking nasty questions is now simply a
journalist doing his job Tracy Lee King
has subscribed and Stephanie Meyers says
I just want to say that your content is
great thank you for your work thank you
to your staff as well very important I
appreciate it
let's go over to twitch where there are
many exciting things happening
I want to thank Candi for subscribing
with prime as well as Rick 88 fried
sickle subscribes and says hello from
Philadelphia Jamaica Jamaica whit setter
has subscribed with prime be 34 G has
subscribed with Prime and Gratton B says
hi David just spending my monthly Bezos
money on the best cause I can any tips
on getting involved in politics in a
deep red state like Nebraska yeah find
local races where you can make a
difference and the making a difference
in Nebraska might mean you get a lunatic
far-right Republican replaced with a
centrist Republican like that might be
as good as you can do in Nebraska okay
so you do it fine find local races to
get involved in where you can very often
have a significant impact and and
relatively quickly in some cases for
sure okay other things that I wanted to
go over with you guys
Donald Trump has reportedly threatened
to sue his own campaign manager because
he I know it doesn't make any sense
because he's losing in every poll Trump
reportedly saying I'm not losing to you
know a guy like Biden and threatening to
sue his own campaign manager as you can
see here in the last 24 days Biden is up
in every poll nationally other than a
Fox News poll which is tied if you
believe that then you have to also
believe that from losing in Texas
according to a new Fox News poll which
is crazy Fox News polling is actually
considered pretty good despite Fox News
opinion being trash Biden winning by as
many as 11 in a CNN poll 10 in a USA
Today poll 8 in a Quinnipiac poll 7 in
NBC Wall Street Journal this means
nothing we have 6 months to go
everybody's got a vote etc etc etc ok
Donald Trump has been caught lying I'm
gonna play video for you from Tuesday
and then I'm going to play video for you
from Wednesday on Tuesday Trump said we
will soon be past 5 million tests a day
on Wednesday Trump said me 5 million
well maybe somebody said it I don't know
what you're talking about
certainly wasn't me take a look by June
in order to safely reopen you unveiled a
plan yesterday that will increase
testing but not by that much why not can
you get to that venture well it will
increase it and it will increase it by
much more than that and it will increase
it and it'll increase it by much more
than that also later in the segment from
begin saying that that's the case
testing even though some people won't
even want to use it very soon we're
gonna be at 5 million tests very soon
here's Trump on Wednesday saying what I
don't know what you're talking about
I'd like to refer to these two people
because I don't know where it came up
everyone kept saying you said there'd be
five that was a study that came out said
that he came out with the study of five
many people do I think we will I think
we will but I never said it we're
testing millions of people we're testing
no people than anyone any country in the
world by far by double I'm now having of
course so there it is a very very rapid
very rapid change now here's my question
to you does Trump know he's lying or has
his brain turned to mush and he just
doesn't remember because there are
reports that Trump has no memory that
his memory is just totally gone and that
he doesn't remember it
I I don't know I I don't know the answer
I don't know what to make of it
okay other Super chats that are coming
here let's see here Alexander the Snivy
says if in some alternate reality would
Donald Trump be less dangerous or more
dangerous if he was smarter I think
Trump would be less dangerous if he were
smarter I think the ways in which he's
dangerous now are already because of the
areas where he has competence how to
propagandize etc I think him being like
if Trump understood science better I
think we'd be better off I don't think
that that would make him less dangerous
more dangerous Zachary foster says best
friend in medical school says vaccine
could be at best ready by early
September that's also what I'm reading
the Oxford University vaccine seems to
be the closest one closest one will
spoil says have you heard about captain
Tom Moore in the UK over 30 million
pounds raised for the NHS at 100 years
old I have not heard about that sounds
very interesting and I will check it out
let me say thank you to Mei bird Akal
for subscribing with twitch Prime and
hero Ranga for subscribing with twitch
Prime with the message team Pakman we do
have a hype train happening on Twitch
disregard that if you're not watching on
Twitch and remember that anybody with an
Amazon Prime subscription can subscribe
for free with twitch Prime I also want
to say thanks to I'm inconsolable for
gifting ten subscriptions over on Twitch
Townsend Koch says will Trump be asked
about his history of anti vac statements
and whether he'll encourage people to
get to vaccines to get the vaccine many
of the protesters are anti backs I've
been waiting for that I would love it if
Trump was asked about his previous
anti-vaxxer that would be tremendous
Candida Moreno has grabbed the YouTube
subscription Miz Smith says hello from
the UK sensible talk says I'm here to
learn about exciting new products for
coronavirus customers yeah I think we're
gonna hear a number of those products
today mr. catfish says oh god no I can't
take more of the ask kissing dribbling
down dribbling clown show
that is Donald Trump's coronavirus
update in the mental award think you
mean mental ward that might be a
voice-to-text that went went bad
Daniel Rivera says thanks for the
economic policy Theory deep dive
yesterday David more of that please hope
you're well yeah you know we have to
balance our segments because yesterday I
did a nearly 20 minute deep dive on
fiscal and monetary policy it got like
10,000 views on YouTube and if every one
of our videos got 10,000 views we'd be
out of business
so we always want to balance the types
of things that we are doing Alex Jones
has thoughts on the Tara Reid
accusations of Biden three clips already
up about that three more publishing in
the next 72 hours so I don't know that
we need more of that right now
miss toga and Maximus says hi from
Scotland you are my main source of
American news that stuff was bad here
feel better now yeah if you're feeling
bad about how your country's dealing
with things you can look to the US and
you'll feel better relatively quickly as
Donald Trump likes to say Walter says
any updated information on the
Republican Republican Senate seats in
jeopardy like Susan Collins yes we did a
full segment on it on a to Monday or
Tuesday 'z bonus show so grab a
membership and check out that bonus show
deep dive on it also clips last week or
the week before about Susan Collins
specifically okay the real Ryan Patrick
has subscribed with twitch prime so has
useless legs as well as 420 X weed bong
who subscribes with the message bong PAC
gang and summer vibe has subscribed over
twitch as well oh boy
michael blanco sends a super chat says
hey david my unemployment claim was
finally processed after two months so i
can afford
super chat again LOL good luck to anyone
else waiting we are standing by for the
start of this event at the white house
let me mention we have one primary
funding source for this program its
memberships on my website and they are
dirt cheap my friends so if
you are in a position which I would
consider a good position at this point
where you've not lost your job and you
can put a couple of bucks a month
towards something that you presumably
value you might be here because you hate
me and maybe half of you or three
quarters are but for the few people who
are watching that actually like what I'm
doing consider grabbing a membership at
join pakman.com we were down 389 paid
memberships in March we're down about
350 in April it's the last day of April
it's very ugly and we're all in this
together so if you're not in that
horrible position where you've lost your
job and you're down to your last dollar
I don't want anyone's last dollar if you
can support media that you find valuable
consider getting a membership at join
pakman.com I will thank every person who
does I will do that right now with
Christopher kite
Christopher kite is new member number
one today at join pakman.com and dave
Baumeister is new member number two
today at join pakman.com the coupon code
above my head 20 20 now saves you 66%
okay I almost got into a wrestling match
with my staff today they were saying the
discount is too big my lawyer called
said 66% off is illegal in the northern
parts of Florida as you know the further
north you go in Florida the further
south it gets if you you know what I'm
talking about
but fortunately most of our audience is
not there so this is a very legal and
very cool discount code of 66 percent
that makes a monthly membership two
bucks a month and if you pay for the
year that's at once it's only a dollar
eighty a month a dollar eighty a month
so very very exciting and I did lose the
wrestling match but we are still doing
the coupon code so I guess in a sense I
won we could say I was victorious in the
end I think is the way I would I would
sort of put it okay let's see what else
folks are saying over on YouTube
super chat remember if you're watching
on YouTube press the like button press
the subscribe button always like and
subscribe
very very important ok 22-foot whoa hold
on a second 24 says David when can we
expect a review and glowing
recommendation of the Opus known as
don't burn this book yeah that's Dave
Reubens book I've read enough reviews of
it to know that it's not for me I'm
reading serious literature I'm now
reading killers of the flower moon I
cannot recommend this book to you more
highly it is the story of suspicious
deaths that were taking place in the 20s
among the Osage who are a Native
American group tribe and the book probe
chronicles the investigation into those
deaths and the eventual connection to
the start of the FBI very interesting
book beautifully written and also
another one I recently read called the
secret life of lobsters very interesting
about lobster the lobster industry or
industry as our president says as well
as a lot of science about lobsters that
I didn't know if you want to see
something wild find a video online of a
lobster molting its shell it is wacky
it's like a lobster comes off a lobster
but then right below it there's a
lobster it's crazy but anyway check that
out very very interesting ok
Walker Anderson says check again zero of
your last 200 videos are on Tara Reid
Trump has never been credibly accused of
penetration that's a false equivalence
Trump Trump was accused of actual rape
by at least one of his wives if not also
a 13 year old girl so you're wrong and
again the Tara Reid situation has been
discussed in three of my recent videos
three more coming over the weekend Thank
You Emmett nasty question here what are
your latest thoughts on Dave Rubin if
any none I don't know what he's doing oh
oh oh oh oh you know something very
interesting let me let me just show you
guys one interesting
thing let me see here YouTube this my
attention was called to this the other
day and there's something weird with the
Ruben YouTube channel that I I'm
interested in hearing from people let me
see where this is hold on a second
uh pop up up about detailed statistics
let me see this weekly subscribers now
I'm looking for total subscribers okay
yeah this is this is it right here this
is a little weird if you look at like
the normal way that you actually you
know what I'm not even gonna do it when
you just let me put it this way when I
looked at the subscriber increases for
Dave Rubens Channel something about the
pattern struck me as weird something
about the pattern that's all I'm going
to say I'm not gonna say more than that
something about the pattern struck me as
weird I'm not gonna really get into it
in more detail but that was pointed out
to me the other day and it was
interesting let me put it that way it
was interesting and I think it's worth
looking into okay nasty question says am
i right to be a little worried about
Texas opening tomorrow yes the case and
death count in the DFW are definitely
not on a downward trend you are correct
to be worried you are very much correct
to be worried Charlie says does the
trump presidency confirm simulation
hypothesis I wish it did I wish it did
but sadly I don't I don't know that it
actually does okay let me say thank you
to Martin Fillion who has just upgraded
his website membership at join
pakman.com number three today Nalini
johnson is new member number four at
join pakman.com joy calfy is new member
number five today at join pakman.com
morton hartman Mickelson is new member
number six today i so appreciate that
morton Tyler Davidson has subscribed and
is new member number seven and Judy
patootie has subscribed and his new
member number eight today at join Pakman
really appreciate it we have a very
modest goal of 25 new members and
everybody's welcome everybody's welcome
coupon code is there that saves you 6
per 66 percent it's a beautiful
beautiful thing let me also thank ou ou
do you grok has subscribed with prime
Aggie Archie has subscribed GW Jumpman
has cheered Yuna ferry 79 as well as
Doody duty or uttal duddle has
subscribed oh boy and I really
appreciate that
although I am visibly struggling with
some of these usernames today but I do
appreciate the support very much
inconsolable says apparently things are
getting even crazier in Michigan armed
protesters allegedly attempting to storm
the Capitol building it is getting nuts
in Michigan it is getting nuts in
Michigan a retro path acts as David did
you see Larry King dunk on dave rubin
again I did I did and it was painful
isn't Larry King 90 and he was just
running circles it was crazy incredible
TV says thank you for everything you do
David thank you main dings says what
would your wrestling name be I have no
idea somebody gives me an algorithm for
how to figure out your wrestling name
I'll try to figure it out Dana
Engelbrecht
has signed up Alex Jones says I called
into the show yesterday and you kicked
that Anthony person off asking the
question about shap Rios comments on
fascism and the political compass why he
seemed totally reasonable he just
wouldn't stop talking over me it was
impossible to have a conversation so we
wrapped the call I believe that was also
the person with the atrocious connection
right I mean maybe I'm mistaken
no thanks says bless you David loved the
show Danny Thompson says whether Trump's
memory is shot or he's lying comes down
to this does his incessant TV watching
include watching his own videos from the
prior day or not PAC maniac time PAC
maniac for life keep up the great work
Evon chambers says Donald Trump is the
Tonya Harding of 2020 I have not heard
that before I have not heard that before
Candido Moreno says do you think Biden
is the lesser of two evils well he's the
better option you know call it what you
want
he's unquestionably the better option
truth seeker has signed up Madeline
Welsh says came for the political
analysis stayed for the description of
lobster molting the world of lobsters is
fascinating I highly recommend that book
I mentioned earlier let me say thank you
to a few other people I'm about to have
some issues with pronunciation oh my god
there's a guy with a mag a hat guy with
a mag AHA and a mask here dear God
expect the propaganda I hope everybody's
buckled in
thank you to our SH Cowan who is new
member number nine today at join
pakman.com Cindy Garcia Cindy thank you
you are new member number 11 Marla ank
is new member number 12 today thank you
very much Cheryl walls is new member
number 13
NIC Nicola gap is new member number 14
at joined pakman.com Michael lop Kowski
you are new member number 15 Thank You
Matthew McMurran is new member number 16
and i also want to thank arturo perez
who is new member number 17 today join
pakman.com absolutely love it absolutely
love it and remember we are counting
patreon today as well everything counts
as you can see it's 17 of 25 website
members and patrons if you prefer you
can go to patreon.com/scishow and you
will very strongly be included in my
thank-yous today ok mr. catfish jr. says
well the DNC have buyer's remorse about
Biden and now he's turning into a
Hillary Clinton style election and do
you think they would put someone else in
his place I believe unless Joe Biden
or falls into a coma he will be on the
ballot in November
green lover says greetings from the UK
love what you do man peace at you all
III was just in the UK before this
entire thing got going had a beautiful
time in London took the Eurostar to
Paris there was a strike going on in
France at the time so a bunch of trains
were delayed and it was it was pretty
hectic but an amazing time I stayed in
the what was this in the Harley Street
area in London I believe known for
private surgery consultation clinics
doctors whatever you would call it great
area loved it
great cafes around there and went to a
great cafe called caffeine with a k'
very very clever and not harlot Street
Harley Harley Street and then France was
just fantastic I mean I've been to Paris
a few times and it's one of my favorite
places it was it was delightful
delightful hopes to get back when all of
this is over David Mello says odds that
today's conference will be more garbage
than yesterday I think there's a good
chance today is more propagandistic than
yesterday for sure very much though
Kowalski from Nebraska says if a debate
between Biden and Trump were to happen
and one had a stroke on stage how would
anyone be able to notice all right
Gabriel Garcia says have you looked into
China's rising influence over European
countries Portugal Greece and Hungary
I'm familiar with it in the Hungarian
context I'm not familiar with the
Portuguese and Greek context but I will
absolutely look into that let me say
thank you over on twitch to Jodi
motionless who has subscribed with prime
Parkman voted for Tulsi okay has
subscribed with prime Papa smoke has
subscribed and says how time flies
five months already I read my Tharin
says thanks for everything David with
their four month subscription and
grenade Raven
has subscribed with prime as well which
is absolutely fantastic if you're just
joining us we are about 20 minutes past
the scheduled start for today today is
how is uh the White House describing it
president Trump delivers remarks on
protecting America's seniors from what
I've read Trump is expected to announce
in the context of protecting seniors
that they should stay home but that he
will not be extending the guidelines
beyond today remember that trumps 30
days to slow the spread after the 15
days to slow the spread and today and
there's been a question is he going to
extend those or not from what I've been
reading Trump is not going to extend the
guidelines but is likely to say states
have got it at this point it's sudden
it's follow what your governors are now
saying and everything's great of course
I would anticipate that he is going to
say I'm a few other people that I want
to say thank you to Andrew sleet has
just subscribed on my website and his
new member number 18
Steve zaminsky is new member number 19
today Howard Ehrlich is new member
number 20 at join pakman.com I also want
to say thank you to James Slater who is
new member number 21 BT more is new
member number 22 at join pakman.com and
Morton Lil Moe's is new member number 23
today we've had two people named Morton
sign up for membership in the last
fifteen minutes isn't that remarkable I
know I mentioned on a recent stream that
we have a ridiculous number of people
named David who are paid members to the
show and I was thinking out loud do you
think that there's a unconscious bias
where because my name is David people
named David are subconsciously more
drawn to subscribe to this show than
other shows what do people think because
from from the numbers we have I don't
remember how many members named David we
have it's a crazy number it seems more
than mere chance I would want to see the
p-value on that I guess is what I'm
saying okay let's
here other super chats coming in okay
Carl Smith says what are your thoughts
on balancing free media and controlling
dangerous disinformation are these
incompatible extremes they are not what
we need is respond responsible
platforming takes care of 99% of what
you're talking about there and I have a
couple clips on my youtube channel that
I would encourage you to check out okay
man dings 36 says what distraction or
culture war do you think Trump will cook
up and milk for the summer to take the
focus away from the pandemic if you had
to speculate the continued the media has
treated me so unfairly stuff continuing
to sort of foment protests and states
and positioning himself as being on the
side of freedom against governors will
probably be I mean that's very
culturally related because look at who's
doing it it's Tea Party types right so
there's that there's actually a huge
cultural element to the open America
protests wouldn't be surprised to see
Trump pull something related to Iran
potentially I think there's there's and
there's almost endless possibilities
quite frankly MJ 4/20 has subscribed on
YouTube Zelda freak says in Georgia
there has been an ice cream truck every
week during the stay at home order my
faith in my neighbors not keeping their
kids from grouping at the truck every
week scares me
can you imagine Alex Jones says are all
calls uploaded to YouTube if so when
most calls are uploaded to YouTube the
only time we might not upload one is if
we get a situation where you really
can't hear the person if it's like a
30-second call where they get
disconnected before there's any
substantive discussion we might not
upload it otherwise calls are uploaded
to YouTube and they're uploaded to
YouTube on Friday Saturday and Sunday we
take all the live calls from the Friday
show and we put some up on Friday some
up on Saturday some up on Sunday
occasionally if it's a very full weekend
on YouTube will hold one for Monday but
in that three day period general
speaking hare tieran says many pair as
well yeah we have a few we have quite a
few members named pair interestingly and
I think most of them are from Sweden
unknown prodigy says people search for
their name on YouTube that's why okay
William Logan says thanks for posting my
quote of the day yesterday Cheers
Dominic Richardson says whenever Trump
leaves office will the Republicans run a
standard guy like Jeb or Ted Cruz or
will they have to run another Trump type
just to survive
I think it'll depend on how well it'll
it'll depend on two things one has did
Trump get reelected and then is he
leaving if Trump gets reelected I would
expect someone that is Trump like in
2024 if Trump does not win in November I
would expect something not Trump like in
2024 that that's my guess and of course
I know nothing and my predictions are
worth zero let me say thank you to K
kitchy who is new member or is a patron
and we are counting them as number 24
today Marta Brewer is new member number
25 today so let's let's go for fifty and
see if we can do it Jeremiah grant is
new member number 26 today at join
pakman.com Sima Verma is here and it
looks like folks are sitting down so I
anticipate that this will start pretty
soon pretty soon would be my guess
another quick thank you to Beth
Cintron who's new member number 27 today
a couple of other super chats coming in
as we stand by Oh dr. Burks is in the
room interesting Danny Lorenz has
subscribed martin van Gorp says police
say again I love Belgium keep up the
good work David following you every day
I absolutely love Belgium Belgium is one
of the places I most enjoyed in Europe
went to Brussels went to Antwerp went to
Ghent and went to Bruges they were all
fantastic there's a really great
restaurant in Brussels called Nord Z
there's also I'm to remember the French
name is
something du Nord the Dutch name is
Nords II and it's an outdoor sort of
fish stand that also has lunch once
things get reopened go to nords II order
the fish stew and probably the razor
clams as well trust me folks
trust me okay Erica East has signed up
on YouTube thanks Erica Emma it says
David if people named David are subbing
to you above average rates what else
about yourself can you emphasize to get
people to sub I don't know maybe Jews
should sign up at above-average rates I
think that would be lovely
the Empress AR says the virus distracted
Trump from his bent Vendetta
bent on getting even from the
impeachment hoax do you think he'll be
back on that maybe maybe Alex Jones says
will the call about Shapiro be uploaded
to YouTube I don't I don't even remember
that probably yeah
Jose Bruna says do you think Trump would
do a wag the dog to win Oh who's this oh
it looks like they're just putting
Trump's speech up there okay I would
love it if we could get the c-span feed
let me see if c-span is even carrying
this nonsense because I find the c-span
feed to be a good one so to speak it
doesn't seem that c-span is carrying
this so we'll go back to the White House
feed and of course here is the the Fox
news feed let's see here William Logan
has I don't know if Trump would be
willing to do a wag of the dog to win I
wouldn't put anything past Trump but to
be perfectly frank remember that if
you're just joining us do you do not
need to adjust your television or your
mobile phone or your computer this
simply hasn't started yet they are once
again running about a half hour late the
fact that they have this little desk
here suggests to me there will be a
propagandistic signing of something by
Trump we will see what it is if you're
watching on YouTube please remember to
hit like and subscribe it sounds so
insignificant it really does but it so
helps us we are now approaching 831
thousand subscribers
on YouTube and every time someone hits
like and subscribe it just does wonders
for us it really does storm child
William Logan and storm child jewel
jewelry and tarot readings have
subscribed that's quite a mouthful M
says armed protesters stormed Michigan
Capitol building today chanting lettuce
in blocked from chambers by police line
politicians wearing body armor that is
insane the White House stream still
hasn't started despite the fact that
people are standing presumably for
Donald Trump I would prefer to watch
this over on the White House feed if
possible Trump followed very closely
behind by someone okay I guess here we
are so he's not even on mic folks so
we're gonna go over here to the the
White House feed this will be less toxic
and hopefully he's miked up because that
somebody you got to get a mic on the guy
you know he can't I know that what he's
saying is BS but you got to put a mic on
the guy well thank you very much please
there we go no pouches afternoon I'll
sign a proclamation declaring the month
of May to be older Americans month okay
so that's what he's gonna sign that they
call area I have a feeling I am but I
feel good and our country is making a
lot of progress
Alex I won't tell you that making a lot
of progress yeah as we honor the
incredible contributions of our nation's
seniors we're here today to discuss the
unprecedented steps that we're taking to
protect our seniors from the virus all
also announced vital new actions to
safeguard our nursing homes and most
vulnerable citizens as we gradually in
safely reopen our country and it's very
exciting to see what's happening we're
joined today by secretary Alex a czar
Thank You Secretary Robert Wilkie Robert
thank you very much administrators Seema
Verma
Oh God you great job she's terrible FEMA
administrator Pete Gaynor and chief of
National Guard Bureau General Joseph
Lane gal thanks also to Tennessee
Governor Bill Lee my friend thank you
very much bill great job you're doing
it's great being with you too and many
outstanding advocates for America's
seniors who are here with us today thank
you all very much
as we tragically obscene the virus poses
the greatest risk to older Americans
together as one nation we mourn for
every precious life that has been lost
and there have been many there have been
many were so saddened by it through our
aggressive actions and the devotion of
our doctors and nurses however we have
held our fatality rate far below
hard-hit other countries such as Spain
and Italy and United Kingdom and Sweden
we're way below other countries we're
deploying every tool resource and power
at our disposal to protect our seniors
and Americans of every age in background
early on we implemented life-saving
travel restrictions and directed
billions of dollars toward the
development of therapies and vaccines
and that's moving along rapidly
we've moved at a speed that people are
absolutely stunned to see ok we
accelerated treatments including remedy
severe which is reportedly showing
encouraging preliminary results no
mention of horrific story yesterday was
announced missing by God
in early March my administration advised
all nursing homes to suspend all
medically unnecessary visits to help
slow to spread and to protect our
seniors and especially in our nursing
homes they are having a hard time in
those nursing homes we took action to
step up enforcement of infectious
disease standards at nursing homes all
across America we also acted swiftly to
secure our vet
health care facilities and deployed
hundreds of VA staff to help out in
nursing homes nationwide and were being
helped very greatly by the passage of
all of the things that we got past
Robert especially choice so that people
can go and see their doctor when they
have to and especially our seniors we
provided nearly 1 billion dollars in
grants to support home delivered meals
in-home care and other services that
make it impossible for older people to
just do what they want to do we're
helping older people with disabilities
and we're helping them to live
independently we dramatically expanded
access to telehealth a very big deal for
Medicare beneficiaries the number of
Medicare patients using telehealth has
increased from roughly 11,000 a week to
more than 650,000 people a week so
that's from 11,000 a week to 650,000
that's almost an impossible number to
believe right but it's really it's
really something they get used to it and
many people don't believe all the time
after this horrible scourge is gorge
Medicare is also paying for less there's
no one told him it's pronounced scourge
they weren't appropriate at zero cost to
patients we've insured a ventilator for
every patient who needs one nobody who's
needed a ventilator has been without a
ventilator it's an incredible
achievement and we now have thousands
and thousands of ventilators and other
countries are asking us to help and
we're helping are their country's allies
and some that aren't necessarily allies
thanks for about there and big trouble
and we're helping other countries now
with ventilators same thing with masks
we have millions and millions of masks
that was something four weeks ago was
difficult and now we have millions of
masks coming in and already here the
federal government is also funding over
35,000 members of the National Guard to
help States deliver critical supply
to nursing homes and to assist with
disinfecting and testing like a neurotic
lingo to please come up say a few words
about the work of the National Guard
it's been really fantastic Thank You
general please
so again just focusing on safe material
for Trump look how far back you mr.
president and good afternoon everyone
very proud of the National Guard and all
they are doing to help keep our nation
safe here at home and abroad
today are over at 83,000 men and women
of the National Guard are engaged at
home and abroad and 45,000 of those are
engaged directly in the Cova 19 response
from running hundreds of testing sites
around the country to screening
passengers at airports to helping
manufacture PPE to a myriad of other
tasks the National Guard is there we
know this virus doesn't treat everyone
equally and our senior citizens are at
increased risk in many states governors
have directed National Guard members to
help sanitize long-term care facilities
nursing homes giving older citizens and
families and caregivers peace of mind
that their environments are safe the
Georgia National Guard for instance has
done this has sanitized over 700 nursing
homes and this has been replicated at
many places around the nation and
continues to grow additionally food
banks and homeless shelters in normal
times these are often staffed by our
volunteers many of them are elderly
senior citizens here in America now
volunteering puts those great Americans
at increased risk so the National Guard
is helping these Americans stay clear of
this risk and doing that the National
Guard is staffing many food banks across
the nation where they need the need for
food assistance is increasing across the
nation as this virus continues to
persist the National Guard is a big part
of our United States Army and our United
States Air Force and we're proud of that
but this role that we play here at home
in the homeland under the command of the
governor's in our States is distinctly
and uniquely National Guard
and we're very proud of that so mr.
president thank you thank you for the
support that you give our military in
the National Guard and all the men and
women who serve they are proud to serve
our nation thank you for let me talk
about the guard tonight thank you sir
thank you wow that's great great job
four stars it's a lot of stars very
impressive that's right but that's okay
that's very impressive
you deserve them I do want to say you
mentioned the word governor and we've
had a lot of great success and
relationship with the governor's we've
dealt with our governor's interesting
second well we have really I think got
to understand each other to know each
other in many cases really like each
other and that's worked out very well
we had Phil Murphy here from New Jersey
Governor of New Jersey today wonderful
man a lot of progress is being made
there and we had John bel Edwards
yesterday from Louisiana and run to
Santis the day before from Florida were
just from a couple guys three very
exceptional men and they're doing a
really good job as you know as you know
so and we have others coming in come in
one or two a day and we're seeing them
and whatever we can help them with we
help them with it we help them with very
very quickly general right so it's been
very good my administration is doing
everything possible to support the
state-led management of nursing homes
and here today is a governor who
happened to like a lot and he's done a
fantastic job in a fantastic state a
state that I happen to like a lot it's
called Tennessee right Oh what is it
some reason they like me I haven't
figured that out but they like me in
Tennessee so that's good bill please
come up and cover your education and
Billy it explains that of course state
that a lot of struggles with health care
and education actually thank you very
much mr. president and thank you to your
team many in this room that we have
worked with you are guiding America
through a tremendous crisis and you're
doing it incredibly well and America is
very grateful for that and we are
grateful in Tennessee for the
partnership the partnership between the
federal government
and states like ours as we work to make
our contribution to fighting covered 19
we can do so because of the work that
you're doing in the way that you're
supporting what we're doing so right mr.
president you've asked States to commit
to a goal of testing 2% of their
population in April two percent of
Tennesseans were tested and we have
tested over a hundred and seventy-five
thousand to date but as we look to May
to to build upon that we're actually
strengthening a commitment particularly
to the elderly the most vulnerable of
our citizens especially those in nursing
homes you know there's a scripture
describes being hard on the side but not
crushed or and that's where we are in
Tennessee I think that's where we are in
a nation but the elderly are most
hard-pressed in this setting and
especially those in long-term care
facilities and their need our help
so in Tennessee were committed to
testing every resident and every staff
and every one of our 700 long-term care
facilities it'll be a great undertaking
but it honors the value of these lives
in those facilities lives that have
protected our country in the hardest of
times the greatest generation and those
that have a loving legacy of being our
neighbors and our friends and our
grandparents and and it's time for us to
protect them it's this guy gonna read
some salt we we should do so pursuing
social distancing for example in every
way that we can with them and the
distances sometimes a great gulf I have
a hug my own elderly mom and in a weeks
but we're doing right by these citizens
and you're doing right by committing to
these citizens to make certain that they
that that we do our personal part to
make sure that they're safe and while
valuing our freedoms all at the same
time so well I think as a country we may
be hard-pressed on many sides we are not
crushed and we are grateful for your
leadership and for this team's
leadership and particularly your
commitment to
the most vulnerable in our nation and
together we will get through this thank
you very much sir thank you though
can you imagine thank you very much
great governor by the way horrible as we
take steps to safely reopen our country
we must remain especially vigilant in
sheltering the most vulnerable older
Americans to that end today I have
several important announcements here we
go first in addition to all of the
supplies we've already distributed FEMA
will send supplemental shipment said I
have to tell you Pete what a job you've
done everybody was at the last call with
the governor so many of the governors
said I want to thank him for calling he
would called on Easter morning and he's
calling them all the time and you call
them on Sundays and you call them every
time all the time and I tell you they
really appreciated it they really do
you've done a fantastic job Pete Gaynor
FEMA but FEMA will send supplemental
shipments of personal protective
equipment to all 1,400 Medicaid and
Medicare certified nursing homes in
America right there second CMS is
providing States with 81 million dollars
from the cares Act to increase their
inspections of nursing homes at this
very critical time we have to do that we
have to do that it's a it's a spot
it's a spot that we have to take care of
I guess you could go it a little bit of
a weak spot because things are happening
at the nursing homes that we're not
we're not happy about that we don't want
it to happen so we're checking that out
very carefully and very methodically
fair this week we'll be finalizing a new
rule requiring information about
coronavirus cases and nursing homes to
be reported directly to CDC and testing
data to be posted online so everyone
gets to see it this rule also requires
nursing homes to report cases to
residents and their family members and
finally to ensure that our nursing homes
are prepared for any future outbreaks
we're announcing the coronavirus
commission for safety and quality and
nursing homes this commission will be
compiled
leading industry experts doctors and
scientists resident and patient really
low family members infection and
prevention control specialists and state
and local authorities it's a big deal
the Commission will convene in May and
issue recommendations for fir the steps
we can take to protect our nation's
seniors my administration will never
waver in its relentless commitment to
America's seniors we owe them a sacred
and unbreakable obligation and we will
fulfill that obligation with every
resource and power that we have we are
working very hard with our seniors and
we're working very hard with our nursing
homes and great progress is being made
and will be made that I can promise you
that's also why we are strongly
protecting Medicare and Social Security
we will protect your Social Security we
will his budget would have cut those
things fortunately that budget didn't
have a chance but that's what he
submitted as American citizens and that
goes even beyond seniors we're
protecting this country our chair our
seniors and rich every aspect of our
national life these great citizens have
dedicated their entire lives to our
families and our communities and our
countries our country could not be
anything near word is without our
incredible seniors we'll show them the
same love and loyalty they've shown us
and they've shown our nation every day
of their lives no effort will be spared
to give America's seniors the care and
support and devotion and love they have
earned and that they deserve in a few
moments they'll sign a proclamation
zzz's are designing a very special we've
designed a very special plan and it's
going to designate older American Month
so this is older Americans month but
first I'd like to ask secretary is
secretary will key administrative
mr.bruno strata gainer to share what
their department and agencies are doing
well foundation seniors can ask um one
of them's be maybe you could say a few
words and
a lot of progress come Alex what are you
say well thank you mr. president for
your leadership during this pandemic and
for the work you've done this is the guy
who early in this crisis hired a dog
breeder to run the day-to-day of
coronavirus response for HHS a guy I
mean okay
they were labradoodles it's a beautiful
dog but still you know it's like a it's
a DA former dog breeder he hired to keep
older Americans healthy and safe in
addition to our public health and health
care efforts president Trump has secured
historic investments in programs that
support older Americans and help them
live independently over the past month
HHS has dispersed more than 1 billion
dollars in grants to Aging and
Disability networks which our state and
local agencies like a Council on Aging
that provides services for seniors
living in the community this is more
than a 40 percent increase in the annual
support that we provide to these
critical organizations services that we
support they include delivered meals
like my grandmother used to get for
meals on wheels helped with trips to the
grocery store or the doctor and
assistance with chores in the home back
in March we put out two hundred and
fifty million dollars in grants
specifically for meals including through
Meals on Wheels we've been pleased to
see communities get creative with these
funds some states are ensuring not only
that the meals are getting to seniors
but that the meals are coming from local
restaurants whose businesses are
struggling it's not just about meals and
services we also recognize that older
Americans may be facing mental health
challenges and feeling isolated
Florida's aging Network for instance is
combating social isolation by providing
electronic tablets to nursing home
residents to help them communicate with
loved ones we're also working to protect
the rights of older Americans in
accessing health care our office for
civil rights has been taking action to
ensure that states and health care
providers do not discriminate on the
basis of disability or age in the
allocation of
Oh care we've already had two states
removed such discriminatory policies
from their triaging guidelines as a
result of our office for civil rights
were Trump's board and this finally as
the President and others mentioned we've
worked closely with states to ensure
that they can test especially vulnerable
populations like those living in nursing
homes and those who care for them this
work to protect seniors and empower them
will continue throughout the pandemic as
we reopen our country and keep America's
seniors as healthy and as independent as
possible thank you all for what you do
in this effort
I'd love to get to some questions given
that the full press is there but they've
been squeezed to the back of the room
see you there all along the very far
back mr. president thank you and thank
you for everything you have done to
transform the Department of Veterans
Affairs on behalf of the nation's nine
and a half million veterans seventy-five
years ago the men of the 28th marine
regiment raised the American flag on
Mount Suribachi no event better evoke
the sacrifices triumphs of the 15
million Americans who put on the uniform
during World War two a few years after
he would Jima the soldiers of the United
States 8th army defend who oppose on
perimeter and Marines fought through and
out of the Chosin Reservoir veterans of
those terrible times are still wondering
why this it's going this is going on
it's because the alternative is Trump
wondering about hitting the body with
hit heat and light and injecting
disinfectant so that instead they have
this those precious Americans the
Department of Veterans Affairs has 134
nursing homes but more than half of the
residents in those nursing homes fought
in wars with battles with names like
Guadalcanal and the Bulge and Inchon of
the 78,000 residents in our nursing
homes we have tested all of them from
things the Battle of the Bulge is trying
to stay off of those taco salads from
Trump Tower that he likes
our affection rate is low many of our
homes have few if any positive cases but
still as the president noted we had to
make a very tough decision early on
after all of these veterans had gone
through so much on the battlefield we
had to tell them at this stage in their
lives that we were depriving them of the
sustenance of their families and friends
because we had to protect their lives
because of the president's directions to
me we have been able to contain the
virus in our nursing homes and now we
have taking those less certainly
containing them in the nursing homes and
it costs wildly within them to protect
patients across America we are the
federal experts in gerontology we are
helping 38 states and territories handle
the surge of patients dealing with this
virus with our partners our great
partners at FEMA and even by direct
action through the governor's aiding
America's elderly is central to all of
our efforts we deployed VA staff as the
president noted to veterans nursing
homes owned and operated by the
individual states early on governor's
Charlie Baker and Phil Murphy moved to
protect their veterans and they asked us
for help
in addition Baker's our governor here in
Massachusetts I one point a few days ago
half of our deaths were nursing homes
and long-term care facilities half
Oklahoma Rhode Island in Texas we have
taken in non veteran nursing home
patients and state veterans nursing home
patients into our VA facilities we are
helping elderly Americans wherever we
find them mr. president you should be
very proud of this VA that you have
helped build thousands of VA employees
have left into harm's way
VA leaders like Joan McInerney and
Martina Parata in your
hometown Ryan little in Boston Rieman
Nelson in Detroit Vicki Braun in
Illinois and Wisconsin Fernando Rivera
and Skye MacDougall in New Orleans and
Miguel La Paz in Florida all of them
have put service before self to protect
the most vulnerable and deserving these
are the folks who made America strong
and free thank you very much Thank You
mr. president
okay thank you for your commitment to
the nation's seniors and to the Medicare
program you've been very clear with me
since day one that you wanted to protect
and strengthen the Medicare program and
under your leadership our Medicare
Advantage program is seeing premiums at
a 13-year low and in our Part D program
it's a seven year low but today I want
to focus on nursing homes in the scheme
of life decisions placing a loved one in
a nursing home has to be one of the most
difficult decisions and when you make
that decision you want to know that you
can stay connected with your loved one
and that they're going to be safe and
have the best quality of life and that's
why the decision to restrict visitation
in nursing homes was a heartbreaking
decision and our thoughts and prayers
are with the families and the patients
during this very uncertain time but the
tragic reality is that the coronavirus
seemed almost tailor-made to put major
pressure on nursing homes and countries
across the world have struggled with
their nursing home populations
you know Trump sitting there thinking
how am I losing to Biden in every
frickin poll right now lies and even
before the coronavirus we have been
working on a strategy to improve quality
in nursing homes the strategy focused on
quality oversight in
enforcement and transparency for
patients and their families so they
understand exactly what's going on in
nursing homes about the conditions there
and reducing regulatory burdens so that
nursing home providers can focus on
providing care to their patients instead
of paperwork we've overhauled the entire
survey system and implemented a common
tool across the entire nation to ensure
that our inspectors were being
consistent objective and that's actually
resulted in an increase in the number of
finds and we've updated our websites so
that patients and their families have
the latest information on the quality in
a nursing home and making it very clear
when nursing homes have had significant
cases of abuse and neglect and those
improvements that we've made made it
possible when the coronavirus hit notice
how some of these things are related to
coronavirus some of them are completely
unrelated but this is the strategy they
I hope people don't mind not hearing
Seema Verma I think we'll be okay the
after the in Bleach injection Fiasco and
trunk being laughed at globally they
decided we're gonna push an economic
message and that's what they've been
doing all week Monday Tuesday it's been
all economic messages and yeah he ends
up having to take some questions and
yeah he steps in it when the questions
about something medically related but
this is not as bad as this is it's not
doing damage at least and some networks
aren't even taking it at all
February we issued a series of nine
guidance documents specific to
coronavirus and controlling infections
and nursing homes and just for some
perspective normally these types of
guidance documents can take months
sometimes years like think about it the
strategy is stay out of the news in the
sense of there's really no meat here
it's like okay oh it was reported today
that the Trump administration working
with Seema Verma has created documents
to give to nursing homes oh okay I mean
like it'll be reported in some mild way
but there's really the there's no when
there's big news from these it's very
bad very very bad or just announcements
about extending guidelines inspect
nursing homes and our guidance has
called upon state and local leaders to
support nursing homes in their efforts
to control the corona virus outbreaks
and I commend governor Lee and governors
across the nation that have implemented
our guidance whether it's cleaning their
facilities testing and creating new
kovat facilities and that helps isolate
patients that are sick and keeps other
patients safe and this work has been
critical to keeping nursing home
residents safe and I'm pleased to
announce that we are putting out new
state grants to support state and local
efforts to nursing homes the president
has been an advocate of this he has
asked for increased funding to inspect
nursing homes every year in his budget
but this is the first time that Congress
has provided this funding and the money
couldn't come at a more critical time
will be important to work with our state
partners to ensure safety in our nursing
homes but the president has directed us
to do more and so as part of our opening
up America efforts we are going to
oversee the coronavirus Commission for
safety and quality and nursing homes and
the Commission will comprehensively
assess the response it will identify
best practices and also provide
recommendations for how we go forward to
protect our nursing home residents and
make sure where are the tests exactly be
of life and in closing I want to speak
directly to our nursing home residents
their caretakers and their families your
pain is our pain and we are doing
everything we can to support you and to
the health care workers on the front
lines providing care and comfort to our
nursing home residents we thank you and
thank you mr. president for your
consistent leader
and unwavering support for our elderly
citizens imagine that that's right we're
doing everything we can to lower the
price of insulin for our seniors and
we'll have some great announcements
coming up very soon to lower the price
news okay
Thank You mr. president
administrator Verma and members of the
coronavirus task force let me focus on
the logistics in our effort to deliver
personal protective equipment care
packages to those Rhode Island accent
for people who say it sounds Boston I
believe this is Rhode Island across the
country thanks to the leadership of the
president and the tremendous support of
the White House Corner virus task force
FEMA will deliver care packages
containing four items of PPE to more
than 15,000 medic Medicare Medicaid
certified nursing homes nationwide to
include the District of Columbia the
Commonwealth of Puerto Rico and Guam
given the lack of availability of PPE
necessary for health care workers
providing support for nursing homes we
will provide a package or a kit
containing a seven-day supply of eye
protection masks gowns and gloves to
these 15-plus nursing homes each kit is
individualized for each nursing home
based on the level of staffing and the
seven days of our supply calculation
over the cost of the next 60 days when
providing each of the nursing homes with
two separate shipments of seven days of
supplies totaling 14 days of supplies by
the beginning of July the first shipment
of supplies begins next week these
initial shipments will focus on
metropolitan area sites such as New York
City northern New Jersey Boston Chicago
and Washington DC the second shipment of
supplies begins in early June the goal
is to have all supplies delivered no
later than July 4th assisting us in this
endeavor is federal resources a small
business based out of Stevensville
Maryland who specializes in chembio
equipment support with focusing on
kiding solutions for the Department of
Defense they will help us distribute the
PPE items 608 thousand pieces of eye
protection 6.9 million surgical masks
6.4 million gowns 31 point four million
pairs of gloves and finally I would like
to extend my gratitude to the president
for his leadership on this project as
well as to thank my fellow members of
the White House corner virus task force
in their continued partnership together
we have turned a critical demand for PPE
for our seniors and frontline hit health
care workers into reality
thank you sir so now a little propaganda
sign session will be taking place and
nobody really wants to get focused on
Trump having to call people up of course
and it's all got to be just right man
the propaganda is thick Alexei's are
almost just knock over the flag people
standing nice and close
Wow can you can you imagine why are they
doing this now it's called Tropico Burks
has popped up there Oh get that
Kellyanne dear God should he even be
touching that
and there's Trump showing it with his
big Dookie signature somebody please
make some okay take this make some funny
memes of what is written on the paper
when Trump holds it up and send them to
me we will use them on social media from
handing out pens now some of these
people they're like what do I have to do
this kelly-ann for example like what on
earth could you have to do with the
signature of this birth so gay no social
different ask well thank you very much
and if you'd like to have some questions
maybe on this and we might venture into
different territory also I think John
please yes
not a wise one but if we said we
adventure straight into other territory
the vice president said just a short
time ago he believes the General Michael
Flynn may have unintentionally lied to
him or misspoken when he talked to him
and did not include his meeting with the
Russian ambassador to the United States
do you believe that general Flynn may
have
unintentionally well I really have to
talk to the vice president but I'll tell
you what general Flynn was under
enormous pressure and it was an
artificial pressure because what they
did to general Flynn was a disgrace well
it was a total disgrace it's shocking so
here what they did was interrogators
prepared to interrogate him and there
there they claimed to have these smoking
gun documents where an interrogators
wrote what they were hoping to get from
an interrogation talk to any
interrogator this is what they do they
make a plan they look before the it's
this is now the new this may actually be
the distraction that Flynn was
railroaded listen of this country yes
please Michael Flynn would come back
even bigger and better so are you going
to pardon him and if so are you
considering to bring him back into your
dwell it looks to me like Michael Flynn
would be exonerated based on everything
I see why not the judge but I have a
different type of power but I don't know
that anybody would have to use that
power
I think he's exonerated everything I've
never seen anything like it what they
did what they wrote you see this general
you wouldn't want this happening to you
what they did to general Flynn it's just
disgraceful so you know I guess we'll
get to that
maybe someday or maybe not already we
will have to get there well I think he's
a fine man I think it's terrible what
they did to him it's something that
nobody's asked me but you're asking me
for the first time I would certainly
consider it yeah he would consider push
back I think he's a fine man I think
he's got a great family he loves his son
I will tell you his son was around a lot
and he loves his son and son is arguably
implicated generally do and they did
everything possible to destroy him
and he's still breathing very strongly
but lames worst mistake was agreeing to
work for Trump and then everywhere thing
was downhill from there quick follow in
what capacity of
rotavirus related question but what
capacity would you bring him back well
we look I mean I'm not even this is
really the first time I've been asked
the question but I think he'll be fully
exonerated one way or the other and so
certainly he'd be capable of coming back
he's suffered greatly skew about
comments by your son-in-law one of your
top advisors Jared Kushner yesterday
said that the government's response has
been a quote great success story is that
the write up a little bit problem your
son-in-law out one of your top advisers
Jared Kushner yesterday said the
government's response has been a quote
great success story is that the right
tone and message the facts I mean he's
not talking about other things that I
talked about in my speech today that I
speak about all the time and that's
death it's horrible that what this
country has gone through and what the
world has gone through frankly this is
something could have been contained at
the original location areas that are
contained relatively easily yes China is
a very sophisticated country and they
could have contained it
they were either unable to or they chose
not to and the world has suffered
greatly but what Jared was talking about
and what I talk about a lot is no I
don't think anybody send the job that
we've done other than at public
relations because the press just won't
talk about the facts we had a ventilator
problem that was caused by the fact that
we weren't left ventilators by a
previous administration the cupboards
were bare as oh my god it literally said
not only are there cupboards full now we
have ventilators with a king in the
world of ventilators we have thousands
and thousands of them now being
delivered someone click that that was
the most conferences over the last few
days the governor's never they said
we've never had a case where we couldn't
get a ventilator and at that a month and
a half Lippitt an email he believes you
we're screaming ventilator ventilator
I'm just looking at the test numbers we
have more tests we've given more tests
and the high quality tests then every
other country combined na and say
the friend of mine South Korea president
moon called me you know they talk about
South Korea and they've done a really
good job but he said what a job you've
done this is a much bigger country you
understand so why don't you happen
you've done on on testing so the testing
and the masks and all of the things
we've solved every problem we solved it
quickly but to think that now we're
giving thousands of ventilators to other
countries allies and other than allies
to be honest but we're helping other
countries where people are dying because
we have ventilators and nobody else does
to this extent and it's a great tribute
I mean Deborah we were talking about
that before deborah birx dr. Brooks has
been fantastic she's a fantastic person
a fantastic woman and we talk about the
things that we've done in a short period
of time I mean all you heard about was
ventless that's a hard thing we
energized factories that didn't build
ventilators they were building cars and
other things and now we're building
thousands a week and it's been very
spectacular it's been really spectacular
so yeah I think I don't think anybody's
done a better job with testing with
ventilators with all of the things that
we've done and our death totals our
numbers per million people are really
very very strong we're very proud of the
job we've done yeah we had very little
to work with because the previous
administration left us very little
what do you know well I need it and I
sign it and we do have executive orders
and they help us a lot and they've
helped us a very lot here a very we also
sign things having to do with production
as you know I've used that very very
powerfully the act and often times I
didn't have to use it I just had to talk
about it
now I'm only signing when we want
something what we want when we need
additional manpower or brainpower or
whatever it is we're looking for at the
time but we again we've done things that
I don't think anybody else has been able
to do what we've done and the country -
this is a very big country as you know
we have a large and very proud of the
country I'm very proud of the way they
they've stepped up now things are
opening as an example governor Lee is
doing a great job in opening up
Tennessee and he's opening it up rapidly
and safely I think he said to me two
words I think about safe and rapid and I
think safe was the first one you
mentioned in all fairness but it was
safe and rapid he's doing it quickly and
safely and Tennessee's a great story but
we have other governors friends of both
of ours that are doing really a good job
I will say this governor Murphy and
Governor Cuomo have a tougher situation
because that's really a hotbed that's a
very very dense area people don't
realize the question was about the
deployment of resources in the Western
Hemisphere related to drugs or said I
mean there's like what I don't even
remember the question but it wasn't
anything like this likewise is working
very very hard and speaking to me all
the time and whenever we can help him we
do and we're helping him and he's
helping his state this what he has to do
thank you
I think the operations doing really well
I think that things are being discovered
that you wouldn't have thought possible
the Abbott machine do a buret laboratory
is a great great scientific I was about
the operation in the Caribbean wasn't it
months ago nobody ever heard of this
machine and all of a sudden boom people
come into my office they get tested it
takes some five minutes so they feel
very good some of them have never been
tested but these are you know equipment
and equipment and and tests that nobody
ever thought even possible three or four
months ago we're being used only now I
looked at the numbers and we're over six
million tests and you add up everybody
together they don't have anywhere near
that so it's it's an incredible thing
and it'd be great if the media could
really portray it the way it is because
we've done some this hasn't nothing to
do with it believe network and when
somebody uses the word successful I mean
it's not really holding success very
successful but if you look at mortality
and mortality rates you know this
country it's a very sad thing to be
talking about who ever thought you'd be
talking about such things
two months ago was in part what we
talked about was the economy how well it
was going but today we have to talk
about that our country has really
stepped up our generals of talk about
our roles have stepped up by the way the
bowling ball it's got the three holes in
it and my hands are so small I can't you
know really use the hole so instead I
just pick it up with two hand like
anything would be as related as this
okay who's next
well China doesn't want to see me
elected and the reason is that we're
getting billions and billions of dollars
many billions of dollars a month from
China's what are they our country
anything
China gave us nothing not ten cents and
whether it was Biden and charge of China
which was a joke because he ripped off
they ripped off our country for eight
years and in all fairness to Biden and
Obama this one oughta long before they
got into office you can go through many
administrations until I came along and
then we signed a trade deal the way
they're supposed to buy and they've been
buying a lot extras what are they doing
to prevent his reelection
to what took place with the virus the
virus situation is just not acceptable I
don't want to put any caste any
dispersions I just would like to see a
sleepy Joe Biden they would take this
country for the ride like you've never
seen before and please send mr.
president like guys the president's
right with the unemployment numbers
coming out today thirty million now
unemployed have you given any thought to
possibly extending the six hundred extra
dollars of unemployment benefits that
are that are given out now they will run
out and that we were not alive they are
looking at it and they're taking a very
strong look and we'll be reporting to
you very shortly I will say this
obviously this is what it is it's this
period of time but I think I view the
third quarter as a transition quarter
and I think you're gonna have a very
strong transition and then I think the
fourth quarter is going to be incredibly
successful I think next year we're gonna
have a phenomenal year economically
well I don't want to say that I don't
want to say that but certainly it could
have been stopped it came out of China
and it could have been stopped and I
wish they stopped it and so does the
whole world wish they stopped it there
are many businesses who are concerned
that is America is back up again because
of a provision in the cares act right
gives an additional $600 they won't be
able to get their employees back because
they make more money staying at home
company what if they come back came back
to work which has caused some governor's
to suggest that they might strip those
people of their unemployment insurance
if they're refused to go back to work is
that something you would support well
we're looking at a lot of different
things I brought this up before it was
done this was a Democrat point and I
said you know some people are gonna be
treated unfairly and some people to be
treated you know they didn't get into
the kind of formulas the way I saw it I
said exactly that this was going to
happen but when you think about it it's
basically what being generous with
people that it's short term and we're
being very generous with people that
lost their jobs or potentially what was
their jobs so it's not the biggest
problem that I've ever heard of they're
getting a little bit more money in some
cases they're getting more money than
they thought they would have gotten a
lot of employees are saying now the job
is more important because the employer
is not going to forget that and but it
was something that I brought up at the
beginning and nobody wanted to listen
yeah please Joe Biden your campaign and
surrogates going after him pretty hard
with regard to these allegations from
Tara Reid what do you say no he'll bite
so I don't think they're going after him
hard with regard to Terrans and what do
you say to Joe why I don't know anything
about it I don't know exactly I think he
should respond you know it's it could be
false accusations like know all about
false accusations have been falsely
charged someone should mention the 46
allegations against Trump
if you look at if you look at Brett
Kavanaugh there's an outstanding man he
was falsely charged what happened with
him
was an absolute disgrace to a country
and I guess three of the four women have
now admitted that and I don't know force
give me a break
I mean take a look 36 years that is look
this is a fine man I saw a man suffering
so unfairly remember the question was
about Biden not kavanah so but I don't
know I can't speak for Biden I can only
say that I think you should respond I
think you should answer them thank you
sir I'm trying to a moment ago you said
that China it's possible they could
chosen not to stop the spread of the
virus you insinuating they intentionally
let it spread well they've done it and
and I'm just saying well one of two
things happened I'd either didn't do it
and you know they couldn't do it from
his competence and point or they let it
spread and I you know I I would say
probably it was it got out of control
but you know there's another case that
how come they stopped all the planes and
all of the traffic right from going into
China but they didn't stop the planes
and the traffic from coming into the
United States and from coming into all
over Europe I mean look at Italy look
what happened to Italy and it's very
lucky this country is very lucky and I'm
very lucky that I put the ban on China
as you know very early on in January we
put the ban on in China and that was a
very early day that wasn't a late day
that was an early date then we later put
the ban on in Europe and if we we didn't
do that as Alex knows we would have had
a problem like you wouldn't have
believed we would have had a problem
much bigger but then you take a look at
what happened to Italy a lot of those
people went to Italy instead and it's
been a very very tough place Italy and
then holding them hold them accountable
is that something you prefer to do now
in the next no I'm sorry that I want to
find out what happened I think we'll be
able to get a very good very powerful
definition of exactly what happened
we're working on it strongly now and I
think it's going to be very powerful but
they could have stopped it they are a
very brilliant nation scientifically and
otherwise it got loose
let's say and they could have capped it
they could have stopped it but they
didn't and but they stopped planes from
going to China but they didn't stop them
from going to the rest of the world what
was that all about
what's changes the following we did a
trade deal and everybody was very happy
there's nobody ever been tough on China
like I've been tough one time Acosta's
question is what changed in your
perspective on the virus the trade deal
is not part of this different things but
one of the things I'd say is how China
and other countries are ripping us off
so recently we signed a trade deal with
China a number of months ago China
Chinese buying billions of dollars worth
of a product or farm product and other
product manufacturing product and it's
been a great deal but then we noticed a
virus and it's not acceptable what
happened it came out of China and it's
not acceptable what happened and now
what we're doing Jim is we're finding
out how it came out different forms you
know you've heard all different things
you've heard three or four different
concepts as to how it came out we should
have the answer to that in the
not-too-distant future and that will
determine how I feel about China but
when I was of course I was very rough
with China
I mean Biden as an example the previous
administration they let China rip off
this country like nobody's ever ripped
off this country the question what on
the virus why did you so dramatically
change your tune on China that's all the
question is get into a great deal for
our country but after that all of a
sudden we heard there's a virus and a
virus is coming in that changes my mind
very greatly that's a whole different
thing so you could have a great deal at
it that was earlier on the trade deal
they made the trade deal earlier on and
it's a great deal would would take it in
billions and billions of dollars that's
not a tariffs were
money in different forms including the
fact that we have a 25% tariff or not we
pay fifty billion dollar business it's a
tremendous amount of money some of that
money I've given to the farmers because
they were targeted by China yeah you
know I gave the twelve billion dollars
I gave sixteen billion dollars and this
year we're going to be givin giving
approximately nineteen billion dollars
to the farmers but well something
happened something happened I don't say
misleading or not I'll let you know that
I mean I'll be able to give you that
answer at some point and they hopefully
not too distant future but I will tell
you you take a look at what happened to
this world a month and a half two months
ago we had the strongest economy and the
history of the world and all of a sudden
I have to close the economy have to
close the country she never did that
we've had tremendous death and Cermak
tremendous sorrow sadness and nobody has
ever seen anything like it and so have
most of the countries of the world most
think of that most of the countries 184
you tell me it's probably low right now
because I've been saying 184 184
countries they've suffered tremendously
it's something that is going to have to
be dealt with should lower the white
house flag to half-mast are you going to
do that and are you thinking about
leading the nation in a mission I would
not mind doing that I would say not only
the white house flag we could we could
do that effect it's something that I
will be talking about later on we have a
meeting or someone gave them a nice
topic setting that up so I think
lowering the flags would be something
very appropriate you know about leading
the country though in a moment of
mourning for all of the lives lost the
more than 60,000 of course I think
anybody can feel any worse than I do
about all of the death and destruction
that's so needless nobody but I also
have to make sure that we handle the
situation well nobody's thinking about
it more nobody nobody has spent more
time
late in the evening thinking about
what's happened to this country in a
short period of time but at the same
time we have to get our country open
again and we're doing that step by step
Tennessee is an example step by step
we're opening up our country and I
really believe that next year we can be
I may be even beyond we have a lot of
stimulus and maybe even beyond we'll see
about by the way package for phase four
but I really hope that we can be as good
or better
I built it once and we're going to build
it again John you said a moment ago you
got information on where this virus
originated the Director of National
Intelligence today put out a statement
saying that they believe it was
naturally occurring that was not
man-made but who is that who is that -
said the Office of the Director of
National who in particular who was the
man who made this there was a statement
that the yoga you would know that a
nation so we'll see that would be your
friend National Intelligence right now I
think I think it's I mean you'd have to
tell me who specifically who made the
statement the statement was just put out
under the office of you see I mean I
have to see the same I just haven't seen
but the question I had was have you seen
anything at this point we're looking
into that joined separately from but
we're looking at exactly where
from Woodgate how that happened
separately and also scientifically
similar give me the name and give me the
my question is have you seen anything at
this point that gives you a high degree
of confidence that the Wuhan Institute
of biology was the origin of this virus
yes yes I Wow I think that the world
that's an organization should be ashamed
of themselves oh boy because they're
like the public relations agency for
China China and this country pays them
almost 500 million dollars a year ago
and China pays them 38 million dollars a
year and understand that the President
of the United States claims to have seen
convincing evidence that the corona
virus came from a lab in Wuhan okay
causing hundreds of thousands of people
around the world to die I think the
World Health Organization should be
ashamed of themselves well I have the
right to do that but sanctuary cities
especially at a time like this that's a
very dangerous thing our law enforcement
hates it they hate it they want we want
safe cities we want sanctuary but we
once sanctuary for our citizens and we
don't want sanctuary for criminals that
came into our country illegally and they
have big records and records I won't go
into the type of crimes but the crimes
are the ultimate and evil in many cases
no we don't want them to have sanctuary
in our country we want to have stronger
borders look I said again we want to
have strong borders I've been saying
this for a long time and I think people
are agreeing with me I really do I think
people are agreeing with me the
Democrats won't have open borders where
people just come in and you're not only
talking about coming in from a crime
standpoint you're now talking about
coming in with not only the disease that
we happen to be talking about so much
lately but other diseases and they want
to have open borders they want people to
pour into our country from NOAA from who
knows where they come no we're not doing
that we have a very strong border now or
southern border and every day gets
stronger because
building miles a day of very very
powerful walls and that's a great thing
for a country that's so important for
our country and very few people are
arguing with it yep so it is a war and I
define victory when it's gone and we
opened successfully we have a successful
country again now it can never be a
total victory because too many people
have died all over the world people have
died in our country in every country I'm
looking at the new list of countries
look at what's going on with Russia look
at what's going on with Spain is so so
incredibly harmed and injured by this so
many people are dying this is this is
not something where you'll go to your
traditional G this was an experience
this is not an experience it's a very
bad experience but what I want is we
want the virus gone and we want to have
a vibrant economy we want people back we
don't want people necessarily sitting
like these incredible people in front of
me where they're sitting six feet apart
and said I mean the I want our country
back I want people to go I you know out
and see football games and baseball
games and basketball and hockey and golf
and all of these sports and not worry
about getting sick and violently ill one
of the things that was very interesting
you probably saw it we put it out before
though was Sweden and you compared the
deaths in Sweden to Denmark and and
Finland and Norway you know it's hard to
believe yeah but Trump did go to college
they it but the deaths are very very
substantially higher in Sweden because
they've used that as an example Brazil
is very high if you look at what's gone
on the graph graphically very very hard
eating Brazil very straight up almost
right Debra very straight up a friend of
mine great gentleman president of Brazil
he's really a friend of mine is a great
man but they haven't a hard time they're
going lunatic herd Sweden one hurt but
you know when they say heard it's really
in Sweden in particular the bars you
can't go to certain tiers you can't go
to bars are open into the
a lot of the people are saying well the
Prime Minister's doesn't have to say
stay in your apartment stay in your
house they're staying there they're not
leaving this is not true so you know
it's really our throat not quite what
was reported lie but the number of
deaths are tremendous in Sweden
compared to the countries that surround
where they did where they did very
strong lockdowns and we were discussing
that Deborah before it's a very big
difference it's a very big difference
but again Sweden didn't go really heard
as you understand it and also the people
of Sweden very smart this thing in the
houses they're staying and they're not
going out and this is not true
let's now are some yeah I guess but
they've lost a lot of people in Sweden
yes we're talking about just a second
ago sure Bob I missed the in the
interruption did you are you suggesting
that maybe you have some evidence that
this was not a naturally occurring virus
we can see what it is you're talking
about the virus and right where it came
from you know we're gonna see where it
is we're gonna see where it comes from
and you know look you've know every
theory hood that you had the theory from
the lab yet the theory from many
different the bats and no the type of
bat and the bat is 40 miles away so it
couldn't have been here and it couldn't
have been there and we have up there's a
lot of theories but yeah we have people
looking at it very very strongly
scientific people intelligence people
and others and what beautiful I put it
all together
and what gives you John I might even
tell us Charlie tell us and and what
gives you a high degree of confidence
that this originated from the Wuhan
Institute of virology I can't tell you
that I'm not allowed to tell you that
Jeff mr. president would you consider
having the United States not to pay its
debt obligations to China as punishment
for the virus well I could do it
differently I can do the same thing but
even for more money just by putting on
tariffs so I don't have to do that you
know we pay the tariffs he still doesn't
get it
standard trillion dollars but we can do
that in a I think probably a little bit
of a more forthright manner you start
playing those games and that's tough you
know we have the dollar to protect we
want to protect the sanctity of the
dollar the importance of the dollar it's
the greatest currency in the history of
the world it's become stronger we have a
very strong dollar that's why we're
borrowing at zero zero interest rate you
know with all of the stimulus that we're
talking about where that sounds good
though general doesn't it we're paying
zero interest so essentially right at
zero interest rate and you want to
protect it's a very good question you
know you say go GTO is we owe you a
certain amount of money we're gonna keep
it but when you start playing that game
you're really hurting the sanctity the
importance of the greatest currency on
earth and we can do it in other ways we
can do it with tariffs we can do it
other ways even beyond that without
having to play that game that's a rough
game speaker on a separate topic but
related speaker Pelosi said that she
envisions up to trillion dollars needed
to help support states and localities
would you support that figure so what's
happening is the Democrats have come to
us and they'd like to do a phase four
and we'll think about what's happening
they want to help the states they won't
help bailouts and you know bailouts are
very tough and they happen to be
Democrat states it's California it's New
York it's Illinois you start with those
three and the Republican states are in
strong shape you know I don't know is
that luck or is that talent or is it
just a different mentality but the
Republican run states are in strong
shape okay okay I looked today so are
you in favor again spoke I spoke with
Rhonda Sanchez who was here yesterday as
I said it
Florida's doing incredibly Texas is
doing incredibly these states are doing
unbelievably they don't know about the
word bailout we had a called phantom
laura de the governor of South Dakota
and they have one of the finest run
States they have a I think a
constitutional amendment they're not
allowed to you know they have to have a
balanced budget and they have a balanced
totally balanced budget they just have a
sales tax it's about the only tax they
have is a sales tax so think of it so
it's a whole different thing but
Republican states are doing very well
maybe the Democrats should have brought
this up well when we wanted certain
things and they did and we said and I
said specifically now let's look at it
later on down the road but they'd like
to do something they want to do
infrastructure I can understand
infrastructure think of it we've spent
eight trillion dollars in the middle
east where we find it and we're not
fixing our roads in this country how
stupid how stupid is it and we're not
fixing our highways our tunnels our
bridges or hospitals even our schools
even it's crazy but but they want to do
things and and the Republicans are in a
much better position from you know I
don't want to use the word negotiating
position but we really are we're in a
negotiating position that's different
because they want to bail out various
states Illinois is in big trouble
the governor understands that pritzker
he understands it but Illinois is in big
trouble is it fair to do that and then
have states that are very powerful and
strong like Iowa and I know Idaho let me
take Idaho look at look at all of these
incredible states and look at what's
going on and how successful they are so
you just take a look and and we're going
to look at it we're going to look at it
I think we want to take a little bit of
a pause
but if we do that well causing tons of
people still haven't gotten any money
okay so just a question on masks but
very quickly to follow up on Jeff it
sounds like you're potentially open to
leader McConnell's call that states
should apply for bankruptcy is that what
you're saying just it's an idea that he
has he threw that out as an idea I've
spoken to him about about it very
strongly and we're gonna see what
happens we'll take a little bit of a
pause we'll see what happens but some
states are in trouble I spoke today I
was with a wonderful man a great
gentleman wonderful human being I think
bill knows him too from New Jersey
Governor Phil Murphy New Jersey is it's
a wonderful state I have to say it's a
wonderful place but it's got a lot of
difficulty in terms of the economics and
the the debt the costs etc so it's in a
different position than some of the
other states that we could mention we
could mention him all day long masks if
I could vice president Pence did not
wear one when he visited the Mayo Clinic
earlier this week he's wearing one today
you are traveling to Arizona will you
wear a mask what is the policy fantasy I
am going to Arizona I look forward to
that I'll have to see the climate I mean
I'm going to look at see you know where
I am here's a place that we all feel
very comfortable everybody spread out
it's a very big room but as far as where
I'm going in Arizona I'm gonna have to
look at the climate I'd have no problem
wearing a mess hey that's good friends I
know I'm supposed to make a speech I
just don't know should I speak in a mask
you have to tell me if that's
politically correct I don't know if it
is all speaking of mists but but I have
I'm gonna be making a speech in Arizona
I look forward to it and depending on
the conditions I would have no problem
where I'll take this guys it's important
for him to actually say this it'll get
me people to wear masks it was it was
very hard to get masks we now have and
we're making millions and what you just
need wasn't at their opening plants and
it's been incredible
the chairman of the Federal Reserve has
said that the economic recovery is going
to be long and slow you have said that
it's going to bounce back quickly what
do you know but he doesn't know well I
didn't hear what he said I can only tell
you that I see it I think it's going to
be a transition quarter the third
quarter I think the fourth quarter is
going to be very good and I think next
year is going to be fantastic because of
the stimulus and I haven't seen a
statement but I think we're gonna have a
great year next year knowing that we
left behind a year of tremendous death
tremendous death it was just a terrible
thing the likes of which we haven't seen
I guess if you go back over a hundred
years 1917 and that was a terrible thing
but that was close depending on your
your account or the account anywhere
from fifty to a hundred million people
that 1917 so we haven't seen it it's
over a hundred years and so
understanding that that was terrible I
think that next year from from an
economic standpoint I mean look at the
stock market people are amazed the stock
market said over twenty four thousand
well it was a twenty nine thousand to
twenty four thousand now is that even
possible considering what we've gone
through right because people are very
smart
they're very many of these people are
very brilliant and they look and they
they see a great future the other thing
the dollar is very strong so when we go
out and do stimulus packages were
oversubscribed at zero I'm think of it
you get your money back at zero it's a
pretty incredible thing the euro is
having a hard time and it's much smaller
the dollar has really become the dollar
is king and the dollars increasingly not
positioned now it's just a lot of
countries are moving away from the
dollar as a reserve currency actually
bigger topic I've done stories on it in
big trouble they're really in big
trouble whereas the dollar is very
powerful very strong so the good part
about that is if you do go out and if we
do want to do stimulus or whatever we
want to do want to borrow at zero and
the dollar is very strong okay
the spires came out of a lab in China
art are you insisting or would you
insist on China allowing us
investigators I don't want to go into
that we're gonna see so far I think John
has been trying to be or at least they
seem to be trying to be somewhat
transparent with us but we're gonna find
out you'll be learning in the
not-too-distant future but it's a
terrible thing that happened whether
they made a mistake or whether it
started off as a mistake and then they
made another one or did somebody do
something on purpose say hey you know I
I don't understand how traffic how
people weren't allowed into the rest of
China but they were allowed into the
rest of the world that's a bed that's a
hard question for them to answer right
yeah please mr. president I'm Kim
jong-un if you've got an update on his
condition and whether it E is a life or
death well I understand what's going on
and I just can't talk about Kim jong-un
right now I just hope everything is
going to be fine but I do I do
understand the situation very well
please China early on were you saying
that you were complimentary of China
because you were concerned about this
well I'm making a trade deal with China
this was before the virus of course
they're gonna be complimentary right I
was very uncomplimentary prior to that
salt oxidation and then every once in a
while the negotiation would break down
because I'm not like Kerry who signed a
worse deal of the Iran deal which was
such a disaster and he never left the
table I left the table a lot anyway we
ended up making a deal and of course
during the course of the deal I was both
complimentary and very uncomplimentary
but the bond was those we ended up
making video before the virus came and I
was very happy with the deal but then
later on that was superseded by a virus
that should not have happened well I
just want to thank you all very much and
we'll see you probably tomorrow sometime
thank you very much so the big thing
today certainly Donald Trump saying he
has evidence but he can't talk about it
that the virus may have actually
originated in a Wuhan lab but he can't
talk about it
he can't talk about it don't don't
forget that listen let me say a few
other thank-yous here as we wind down
make sure to LIKE and subscribe on
YouTube as you go I want to say a huge
thank you to so many people including a
Bernice a qiyam who is new member number
31 today Randy bus is new member number
32 it's heartwarming to see all these
names come in Elijah's ankov is new
member number 33 on my website
Beth Cintron of course I may have
mentioned already and so many great
people so it Carina kopeck is new member
number 35
Andrea Dube signed up as well thank you
to everybody and we'll be back with much
more so soon and new clips we'll be
publishing all night on YouTube it'll be
like I'm here except on some kind of
tape delay
you